[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Washington DC Capitol free-world 650,000
people live work and commute in and
around the city planes trains and cars
crisscross the city releasing harmful
chemicals into the air and increasing
the health risks of citizens due to the
Civic importance of the city it is
plagued by constant congestion and
traffic however air quality has improved
tremendously thanks to the EPA
regulation but there is still a long way
to go until the air in the nation's
capital is completely clean bad air
quality affects the person's health in
many non-dramatic waves which i think is
one of the problems with the issue of
air pollution because there's not a
single dramatic thing it's not like you
break out in purple warts if you breathe
that air but in general your health
declines so your respiratory function
declines your heart performance decline
you're much more likely to experience
bouts of asthma so it's not so much that
it's particularly the causes of
pernicious disease but that it decreases
overall levels of health just for all of
us a certain level of air pollution can
actually reduce the function of the
lungs to up to about 20%
the Clean Air Act of 1963 was the first
federal legislation that pertains to
controlling air pollution but it was not
until a 1970 amendment and the creation
of the EPA that they began to be federal
regulation of air quality standards the
EPA sets national ambient air quality
standards for pollutants considered
harmful public health and the
environment
they set both primary standards which
correspond to levels healthy presented
populations such as asthmatics and the
elderly and secondary standards which
correspond of levels healthy enough
public welfare injection the general way
that the Clean Air Act works is that
there is a list of these major
pollutants ozone particulate matter
sulfur dioxide and several more and the
Environmental Protection Agency which is
a federal agency
sets a standard for each of those which
is based on what is the healthy level
for those epa has six what we call
criteria pollutants they're basic air
pollutants for which we regulate
nationally we set an air quality
standard for each of the six glutens and
as the standards are currently set most
parts of the country meet all the
standards and there are a few standards
which some areas struggle to achieve a
zone is one and that's probably the one
for DC
is the most challenging ozone is
actually one of the the most problematic
of the of the pollutants in this area
and it's mainly from the car exhaust
those oxygens from the NOx and the and
the Sox kind of hit each other combined
and do it there's a photochemical
reaction that takes place that creates
ozone at the ground level what we call
ground-level ozone so where as the upper
level ozone is actually good to protect
us the ground-level ozone is as harmful
to EPA as established standards for six
of these criteria pollutants and for a
host of what we call it air toxic
pollutants air toxics or hazardous air
for you the number one public health
killer is fine particulate matter
particulate matter is a mixture of solid
particles and liquid droplets found in
the air it is formed in the atmosphere
as a result of chemical reactions
between pollutants such as sulfur
dioxide and nitrogen oxide which are
emitted from cars industries and power
plants some particles are big enough to
be seen with the naked eye others are so
small that they can only be seen with an
electron microscope in the 1980's EPA
let analysis based on emerging science
which which which reveal that
the particulates that were of most
concern from a health standpoint were
very fine particulates particles that
were much smaller than we have been
focusing on my particulate matter is a
big problem because the whole story with
fine particulate matter is that the
particles are fine they're small and
they get breathe in through your lungs
which is a tissue that is designed to
bring materials from the outside world
into your body there's something that
you're breathing in so small that it
crosses the boundary between the actual
lung and the circulatory system and can
form blockage different type of
blockages because of our environmental
laws the Clean Air Act in particular and
because of the work of all of these
agencies and all of the other supporting
organizations emissions of our basic air
pollutions have gone down really
significantly red concentrations in the
air have been reduced by over 99%
emissions and air pollution
concentrations of other pollutants have
also been reduced dramatically sulfur
dioxide emissions and we reduce probably
over 80% and emissions of nitrogen
oxides by probably over 60% and
emissions of pollutants that lead to
ozone have been reduced by probably 30
to 50 percent I think those trends are
driven not by a single monumental
landmark legislation or single change
that DC adopted but rather just kind of
chipping away of the problem year by
year and bringing more awareness to this
issue and more consciousness to the
issue I will not say that we're done
we're getting the air of cleaner but I
would certainly say we've made
significant progress
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you